the challenges facing our world are
growing all the time
how do we build stronger economies with
equal opportunities for all
how do we build a sustainable world for
generations to come
how do we protect our cities and harness
the power of technology for our common
benefit
humanity has always been good at forward
thinking
in this series using the latest
bloomberg research and analysis we will
make sense of the problems of tomorrow
inequality
sustainability
urbanization
the gender gap
and the demographic time bomb
and in this film the march of the
machines
what effect will artificial intelligence
have on the world of work will a machine
soon be doing your job
does the rise of the robot mean the full
of humanity
[Music]
the world is changing
today we stand on the brink of a fourth
industrial revolution one that will
transform the way we work the way we
live and even what makes us human
there's a group of technologies that are
combining to create transformation
across almost every industry at the
moment and those technologies include
things like artificial intelligence 3d
printing robotics
big data and then some things in on the
sort of life sciences front in terms of
genetics and medical imaging and that
these things are sort of combining in a
way that's bringing about a host of
transformative changes across industries
i would describe the fourth industrial
revolution
actually quite similarly to how i would
describe the past three and that is
technology that leads to massive gains
and productivity and massive gains in
productivity mean
substantial improvements to everyone's
quality of life
the world has been through revolutions
before the advent of mechanization then
electronics then the digital revolution
all profoundly changed the world's
economies
but this revolution could be even more
disruptive
i think in previous revolutions you
could really talk about them as
industrial revolutions what was changing
was how things were made factories
industry often heavy industry in
particular here you're seeing
transformation across really a whole
range of not just industry but services
and and the creation of whole new
business models that didn't exist before
what's different a little bit about this
particular revolution
is that um
it gets into a whole range of things
that people only thought were ever only
possible for humans to do jobs that work
human jobs before aren't going to be
human jobs anymore
at the heart of this fourth revolution
is artificial intelligence the ability
of machines to match and perhaps one day
surpass the cognitive ability of their
human creators
what's happening now is a big deal um it
is making a big difference in the way
people live
the way people interact with each other
it is sort of obliterating distance it
is in some cases removing humans from
tasks that we once thought were the sole
province of the human mind these
analytic tasks that we thought only a
human brain could do we're suddenly
finding that algorithms can do that
machines can do
these are early days in the brave new
world of artificial intelligence but the
potential benefits are vast
what are some of the liberating benefits
of artificial intelligence they're
actually a lot um if you think about
something just like driverless cars
autonomous vehicles which is one use of
ai that people are talking about that
could have a really liberating impact on
a lot of people's lives if you think
about older people who can no longer
drive they're very shut in their houses
right now very dependent on others for
transportation with driverless cars they
would be able to go about their daily
life and then you're seeing with big
data that this may have a profound
impact on drug development that you'll
find
new pharmaceuticals being developed at a
faster rate
to cure diseases because the computers
are essentially able to sort through the
data
and pick up connections that otherwise
would be missed
for health in particular the advantages
of machine learning data science are
immense those have an incredible chance
to address very both very infrequent
diseases and diseases which affect
different parts of the population very
differently if we're going to cure
cancer it's probably going to come
through data science
but there is potentially a darker side
to this technological revolution one
which could profoundly change the world
of work as we know it
[Music]
a technological revolution will cost
jobs it'll cost jobs in the areas that
see the biggest advancements first a
good example of that that that is
feasible over the near term
is truck driving you have self-driving
trucks
you don't need the 3.5 million truck
drivers that you have right now in the
u.s what is key as part of this
revolution as productivity goes up as
the economy continues to evolve and new
jobs are created you need to make sure
those displaced workers are given the
skills to move into these new positions
that's what's key will all of them be no
but i think the key point is you need to
make sure if you've lost 3.5 million
jobs in one sector how do you create
more than that in another sector and i
think in past industrial revolutions
that's what we've seen happen and
hopefully uh and i think it will it will
be what happens again
but what if this doesn't happen
[Music]
martin ford is a software entrepreneur
he has peered into our future economy
and sees a world where potentially
hundreds of millions of skilled workers
are out of a job
i would say that if you look far enough
into the future there is no job anywhere
in our economy there's nothing that
anyone does that is completely safe and
that includes even artists and
novelists and you know the kinds of jobs
that you would imagine right now are
completely
beyond the scope of artificial
intelligence millions and millions of
those jobs are going to be lost
and it's unlikely that enough jobs are
going to be created to absorb all of
those workers
[Music]
martin ford is a software entrepreneur
who has a chilling vision of the future
his best-selling books have put him at
the forefront of a movement which
worries about technology the speed of
its growth and the immense potential it
has to change the world
this is the fourth industrial revolution
the advent of machines powered by
artificial intelligence which have the
potential to make redundant hundreds of
millions of workers across the planet
it is a world which is nearly upon us
but which governments and businesses are
only starting to comprehend
well the central idea in my latest book
the rise of the robots is that over time
machines computers smart algorithms are
increasingly going to substitute for
human labor i think that that's
inevitable
technology is eventually going to be
able to do many of the things that
people now do and i think there's a good
chance that that will result in
unemployment it's going to push people
out of the labor force many people are
going to find it impossible to adapt to
that because they're not going to have
capabilities that really exceed what
machines can do and that's i think going
to be a genuine concern both for our
society of course and ultimately for the
economy too
some of those machines are already with
us
[Music]
there are already algorithms that can
interpret things like body language and
respond to some extent to emotion that
can determine your mood for example and
so forth and you know this has big
implications imagine what that could
mean for example
for advertising if an algorithm can
determine exactly how you're feeling and
then target
advertisements at you based on that
some of the language trans translation
things that have been demonstrated are
truly remarkable imagine if anyone in
any country who speaks any language
would now be able to do any job because
we have perfect
machine translation in real time between
languages so you know that has real
implications for the job market
obviously
we may already be starting to see the
effect on the wider economy in the first
decade of this century the net total
number of jobs created in the united
states
was zero
what we see is that in the united states
we've been having
what we call jobless recovery so
clearly there's something happening
there and i think part of what's
happening is that
jobs disappear when a recession happens
and then when
finally recovery comes back companies
find that they're able to leverage
technology to avoid higher rehiring a
lot of those workers and so it's taking
longer and longer for the jobs to
reappear
throughout history technology has always
disrupted economies and societies
in the late 19th century 50 of us
workers were employed on farms
by 2000 it was less than two percent
those workers found work in other
sectors
but martin thinks this time it's
different
what transformed agriculture was a
specific mechanical technology
now we've got a technology that's really
just ubiquitous it's across the board
artificial intelligence is something
that's just scaling across our entire
economy it's not something that's
impacting just one sector
it's something that literally is
everywhere and as a result it means that
there isn't really going to be any safe
haven for workers
what makes the new technology so
ubiquitous is the development of a new
virtual world the world of big data
well big data essentially is the
collection and use of just massive
amounts of data in big corporations for
example these companies are collecting
all kinds of information about their
customers about their business
operations about the actual processes in
industrial environments and factories
about the things that their employees
are doing all of this data essentially
becomes a kind of feedstock for these
smart algorithms it it becomes the
information that they use to learn
and and basically to figure out how to
do things and um that's something that
is just going to be i think dramatically
disruptive going forward
the total data stored on the world's
computers is now believed to be well
over 1 000 billion gigabytes
and it is big data which is driving the
most disruptive advance in technology
the ability of machines to think
[Music]
one thing that you'll very often hear
people say even today is that computers
only do what their programs do you know
this is really not right anymore and the
reason it's not right is basically
because of machine learning because we
now have this technology
that allows smart software algorithms to
look at data and based on that to to
learn to learn how to do things to
figure things out to make predictions so
it really is no longer the case that
some human being is sitting down and
telling a computer exactly what to do
step by step
computers are now having the ability to
figure that out for themselves
you can imagine a future where every
device every appliance all kinds of
industrial equipment everything
communicates and talks to each other and
i think that one of the things will
happen is that
artificial intelligence will kind of use
that as a platform it will scale across
all of that everything will become more
intelligent
the last great technological advance saw
robots replace millions of blue-collar
jobs in factories and on production
lines
martin believes this new disruption is
going to target the white collar
workforce as well
once a
a computer learns to do something then
that that information can be scalable
out to any number of machines so it's
almost as like you can imagine having a
workforce of people and you could train
one employee to do a particular task and
then you could clone that worker and and
have a whole army of those workers
that's a bit like the way artificial
intelligence works so machine learning
is is very scalable if you've got the
kind of job where
someone else another smart person could
maybe watch what you're doing or study
everything you've done in the past and
figure out how to do your job then it's
a pretty
good bet that eventually there'll be an
algorithm that will come along and be
able to do you know essentially that
that same approach so
that's a lot of jobs
many of the jobs which might be
displaced are those currently occupied
by educated highly paid workers
so you can see really across the board
that um anyone sitting in front of a
computer doing some sort of routine
predictable knowledge work for example
if they're cranking out the same report
or the same analysis again and again
all of that is going to be very
susceptible to this journalism is one
interesting area that's being impacted
by this because there are now systems
that can essentially tap into data and
then they can transform that data into a
very compelling news story that many
people would read and they can't tell
that it was written by a machine in the
future maybe 90 percent of new stories
will be machine generated
the number of jobs displaced has the
potential to utterly transform the
economic landscape there have been a
couple of studies done most notably by a
couple of researchers at oxford
university and they've looked at a
number of countries and most of the
results have come back
suggesting that up to half of the jobs
could be susceptible to automation
perhaps over the next 20 years
that's 60 million jobs in the united
states alone
that's a staggering number obviously we
have a massive social problem you'd have
tremendous stress on government in terms
of trying to take care of all these
people that no longer have an income
i think that you would see
the potential for a massive economic
downturn because you would run out of
consumers you no longer have people that
are capable
of buying the products and services that
are being
produced by the economy
a revolution on this scale wouldn't just
transform an economy it would have
immense implications for our society
we could really have just what you might
call inequality on steroids the very
wealthy people who own all this
technology are going to do
extraordinarily well
you would have the potential for civil
unrest perhaps even riots or
massive crime waves
in the united states during the great
depression we had an unemployment rate
of about 25
and
back then there were many people
genuinely concerned that that would
result in the collapse of both democracy
and capitalism
this situation amounts to just about the
end of the world as we know it a science
fiction nightmare straight from the
movies
there are some very prominent thinkers
like for example stephen hawking and
elon musk who have
raised genuine fears about the potential
for advanced artificial intelligence and
their concern is that someday we're
going to build a super intelligent
machine imagine a machine that's a
hundred or maybe a thousand times
smarter than any living person uh what
would that system think how would it act
would it have a use for us
uh it might decide that we're simply a
burden it might decide to just get rid
of us so it could potentially present an
existential threat
is that something to worry about i think
that it's not a silly concern it's not
something that we should laugh at and
just dismiss
[Music]
there's really
no end point to this there's no point at
which you can say this is absolutely as
far as we can go and
machines will never go beyond this we
are reaching a new era a time when
things are going to operate differently
and we need to adapt to that
healthcare is one area of the economy
already adapting to this disruption and
in this field researchers hope that
intelligent humans and intelligent
machines can work together for
everyone's benefit
[Music]
the fourth industrial revolution the era
of artificial intelligence has arrived
computers are now mastering tasks once
considered the sole preserve of humans
and putting millions of jobs at risk
and now business leaders are wrestling
with the potentially huge implications
in general
robots of one form or another are going
to become much more omnipresent in our
lives in a good way they'll replace a
lot of repetitive activities that people
are currently doing robots will have a
dramatic effect on the labor pool lower
the cost of products people will start
to realize that just about every manual
task eventually will probably be done by
a robot
martin ford's books have highlighted the
threat to the job market
but even he sees areas where artificial
intelligence could be beneficial
i do think that healthcare is actually
one of the areas where the impact of
artificial intelligence and robotics
could be extraordinarily positive in the
future the burden on our economy is
growing at a remarkable rate especially
in the united states so if we can deploy
more artificial intelligence and
robotics there to make that more
efficient that'll be a great thing
analysts expect the ai healthcare market
to generate revenues of over 6 billion
dollars by 2021 10 times its current
total
young companies like hindsight in new
jersey and analytic in california are
mining data to improve patient outcomes
across a range of illnesses
and in new york ibm researchers have
developed watson an intelligent software
system at the forefront of this
revolution
it can understand somebody's personality
type
it can look at email for example and
tell you what is the tone of the email
uh you know what kind of messages are
coming through whether you internet them
or not right
it can look at for example a big
encyclopedia extract all the concepts
and the relationship among those
concepts
[Music]
watson operates in the world of big data
extracting knowledge from the billions
of facts and figures floating through
cyberspace
i look at the world from the point of
view of
you know the amount of data that there
is um and the amount of knowledge that
is embedded or insights that's embedded
in the data that we're not able to
extract today and therefore we are not
able to make the right decisions
so
um the fourth industrial revolution to
me is the ability to have a much
better understanding of the world
through all of the data and therefore
making better decisions for it
[Music]
ibm is currently running a research
project in which watson augments the
intelligence of medical professionals
helping doctors treat the most dangerous
diseases in the world
including skin cancer
[Music]
melanoma is a very deadly form of skin
cancer and it's something where early
detection and intervention is is key so
a dermatologist faced with a patient who
has a skin lesion will make some
assessment about the likelihood of a
lesion being melanoma
so unfortunately today dermatologists
can make errors some melanomas are being
missed
and some skin lesions which are
perfectly benign are being excised
needlessly
so what we can do here is essentially
ask the computer to make a deep analysis
over an image
so this image is then being sent to the
computer and it's being automatically
analyzed
and what the computer is telling us
about this image is that there's a very
high probability that it corresponds to
melanoma what we're finding in our own
internal retrospective research is that
the computer can be as accurate as 95
percent
so this compares to
the best clinical experts today that are
between 75 and 84 in recognizing
melanoma it is not a tool that would
replace uh the clinical expert rather it
provides them
with additional analysis over the skin
lesion images by providing reaches into
large databases
of similar lesions
[Music]
this is a vision of a future where
humans and machines work hand in hand
complementing one another's skills
i look forward to a time when you know
every professional in fact you know two
three billion professionals around the
world are all able to have their own
personal cognitive assistant that can
help them do their daily jobs and that
changes the nature of expertise humanity
will move to a completely different
place in terms of expertise and how we
apply our knowledge and our experience
into real world problems and therefore
make the world a better place just like
we've had
machines that could um augment people's
muscles in the in the prior industrial
revolutions uh or up can help people
you know search vast amounts of
information like in the in the internet
era i look at the next revolution as
machines augmenting people's cognitive
capabilities
that's how i think about it
martin ford remains cautious believing
artificial intelligence is going to
fundamentally change the way we live and
work
and challenge us like never before
we're not prepared for the disruption
that's coming
we're going to see
things get worse before they get better
in particular the impact on the job
market and the impact on
the incomes and the livelihoods for
average people
so you know in the short term things
could be pretty difficult but in the
longer term if we do adapt to this then
i think there are reasons to be really
optimistic i mean you can imagine
an almost utopian kind of future where
no one has to do a job that's dangerous
or that they really hate or that's
really boring where technology takes on
more and more of that
and if we can get to that point of
course then that's a tremendously
positive outcome so i think that all of
that is really possible and it could be
one of the best things that's ever
happened to humanity but it will require
that we adapt to it and
that's going to be a staggering
challenge
[Music]
you